funcionarios públicos 11 empresarios y
11 órdenes de captura por ejecutar es el
balance que ofreció el fiscal general
Tere William saab tras las recientes
detenciones a funcionarios públicos por
presuntos hechos de corrupción la
mayoría de ellos vinculados a la
industria petrolera el fiscal general
denunció una red de funcionarios
públicos que realizaban operaciones
paralelas a pdvsa que asignaban dineros
a la superintendencia de criptoactivos y
que comercializaban petróleo y cargaban
buques petroleros sin mayores controles
administrativos el fiscal dijo que la
mayoría de delitos que se le ha imputado
a estos detenidos son apropiación
indebida del patrimonio público
asociación para delinquir legitimación
de capitales pero que también se les
imputaría el delito de traición a la
patria dijo además el fiscal que han
logrado recuperar buena parte de los
bienes que se le habían robado a la
nación también el fiscal hizo un balance
sobre órdenes de aprehensión contra
funcionarios del gobierno interino que
presi día Juan guaidó según el balance
fiscal habría 288 órdenes de aprehensión
y 13 personas con pedido de extradición
recordemos que desde el gobierno se ha
anunciado que esto es un operativo en la
lucha contra la corrupción pero desde la
oposición aseguran que se trate de una
pugna interna dentro del chavismo por el
poder